[Music]
[Applause]
Tom Curran was handling pre and post
game with the Patriots and he joins us
the Patriot Insider for NBC Sports
Boston hey Tom
I'm good hey it's definitely not could
you
are there any words that uh new
englanders say that you know slang that
we would go I don't what you just said
yeah
um hey is there a bubbler over there
and that means is there a water fountain
nearby oh okay a bubbler so a bubbler
okay
yeah he was running down the hall he
slipped and he hit his face on the
bubbler
all right um well thanks for coming on
Tom that was really awesome have a great
December
um so uh handicapped the Patriots here
the next five games and the possibility
of making the playoffs then we'll work
our way back to what happened last night
yeah I like that approach you know right
now on paper they're gonna play games
against Las Vegas and Arizona in the
next two weeks a little road trip and
they could very well win both of those
on paper if they play to the level of
their six and six record
and then they have on Christmas Eve
the Cincinnati Bengals who are playing
really well but have been a little bit
Jekyll and Hyde themselves this year so
you have a team who could be nine and
six and then close the season
um at home
with Miami and then on the road at
Buffalo and maybe they don't have
anything to play for so conceivably they
could be 11 and six but that is an
extremely Rosy outlook for a Patriots
team that just doesn't seem to have the
urgency or attention to detail or
boldness that it used to have and
normally had
but what is missing here who's to blame
for the offense
bill
because Bill Belichick decided that Josh
McDaniels leaving was his cue to revamp
the offense to move away from the very
sophisticated and evolved option-based
offense where so much happens after the
snap to something that's more
user-friendly which took away a lot of
what Mac Jones was good at
processing quickly moving the ball
precisely they also went away from a lot
of the wide Zone excuse me the Gap runs
that they they had success with and
additionally in moving away from that
they installed somebody to install it
who basically does HVAC and you're
asking them to fix your car
it was a bad idea and that's where the
that's where the buck stops is with Bill
and he said at the beginning of the year
well if it doesn't work with Matt
Patricia Joe judge blame me so here we
are
who is Mac Jones yelling at on the
sidelines the world
the world is a vampire he is yelling at
the notion of this timidity that the
Patriots have adopted you know there was
a period at the beginning of the year
where they wanted Mac Jones to push it
down the field we're gonna be more
aggressive we're going to get chunk
plays that's why we have DeVante Parker
we can't be standing around in a
division with Tyreek Hill and Josh Allen
and scoring 17 points we're going to get
chunk plays they play the Ravens
he tries for a bunch of Chunk plays he
gets three picks and injured and since
then they have just turned into an
armadillo and you saw it last night
they're afraid of their own shadow in so
many different ways you see it at the
end of the game I think that's Mac just
saying look I'm a pretty good player we
have the get this then they have the
highest paid in terms of cap space tight
ends in the league number one in cap
space allocated third third in wide
receiver cap space allocated in the
league
and then you see that product and you're
like it can't necessarily be all on the
players
that surprises me oh yeah yeah
because I could see the frustration with
Mac Jones it's like I want to throw it
down field but who am I throwing it down
field to it didn't feel like there's
separation there where you go okay we we
have like who is your playmaker Jacoby
Myers
he said with a level of disbelief
um yeah
and that's the thing is they don't have
a hill a Tyreek Hill or stuff and stuff
on Diggs or Justin Jefferson so what you
need to do is beat teams with scheme
which is what Josh McDaniels was always
really really good at doing you'd see
guys running naked and alone because
they had scheme something and set
something up now they did have Quran
they did have Edelman who were
individually electric players and could
separate they don't really have any
separators right now so they need to be
more on top of things with scheme and
Matt is over his head in trying to do
that
we're talking to Tom Curran the Patriots
Insider NBC Sports Boston I don't know
how these stories get started I don't
know if it's a speculation rumor but Tom
Brady hey maybe we could see him going
back to New England then all of a sudden
it became a story yeah it became a
headline it became a report
it did more it morphed very quickly into
a report when I see it seemed to me as
if Jeff Howe from the athletic was you
know dot connecting
Brady's contracts up Patriots he used to
play there why will hey he could go back
well to go back bill was already kind of
greasing the skids to move on from
Thomas 36. at 46 he's going to bring him
back admit a mistake tell Mac Jones to
sit down and watch for a year
and then Brady's going to say well it
was great that you wouldn't give me the
money that I asked for a couple of years
ago and made me moving up my family
after I begged you to stay worked out
great for me but I'm going to say bye
Gods we by gods come back
be under your thumb again even though I
respect you highly
and play with a team with an offensive
coordinator
who used to be the defensive coordinator
and failed with Detroit I just to get
through that additionally to get to the
point where bill says Mac go ahead and
have a seat is uh that's a leap man
that's a leap yeah I can't imagine if if
Tom is that desperate to find a team
that wants to employ him after this year
because that would be there's no reason
for him to go gosh
um let's go to New England I can take
advantage of that offense Randy Moss in
there anymore there there'd be no reason
to go up there and it's not any farewell
tour uh doesn't strike me as either one
of those guys or you know interest
interested in that yeah I think the high
level of respect that you're seeing from
each guy in the appreciation and the
love that they have for each other
that was very well veiled for the last
six or seven years here
is it outgrowth of hey the success that
you guys had together so it's it's you
know
it's the more likely Dan sorry to heaven
and Han but if you look at the Vegas
situation
there's about a 40 million dollar if I'm
not mistaken guarantee that has to go to
Derek Carr soon after the season ends
you see the answer there is he a guy who
plays with kind of the attitude and
aggressiveness that Josh McDaniels won
in in the accuracy or would Brady be a
better fit there yes and if he's looking
for landing spots a place with Darren
Waller and Hunter Renfrow and Devonte
Adams to jettison from there out to the
Bay Area
it would seem like a easier dot to
connect I'll leave you with this since
you just saw the Buffalo Bills the team
to beat in the AFC East is
the Buffalo Bills and I would have said
that before Miami because the bills are
just going through a little bit of a
rough patch but they are just so
unbelievable at quarterback you're not
buying into the Dolphins I am I am I
think there are I think they're a very
good team in all the credit in the world
to Mike McDaniel and what he's done
um in making that team in his
Vision but I just watched to us
sometimes and as many as much as he's
done this year and credit to him
I just don't think that he's a
Transcendent player maybe he will be but
I don't think he is there yet and I
think that Josh Allen is if I said bills
or chiefs
Chiefs has to be the Chiefs Dan I hate
to go with the chalk it's boring as hell
but it's a chance my friend yeah always
great to talk to you have a great week
do you think Bill Belichick is going to
be in New England for as long as he
wants
from the outside perspective that's my
question for you how long does he want
till he says I'm all set say 75. no
that's a long time
say the end of Matt Jones contract 21 22
23 24 25 he gets the Schuler record by
the end of
um next year early 2024.
I'll go back to what Brett Musburger
told me about Joe Paterno there are
certain coaches who coach until they die
that's all they know it could be health
issues but you know they coach until
they die is Belichick a coach until he
dies kind of guy
I don't think so
I think he really likes travel that he
engages in being a Nantucket being
around his grandkids and his kids
um I don't think he's a coach until he
dies guy I think he's a coach for your
place in history and to cement yourself
at the top of you know the Olympus of
coaches I think he's he is that guy so
he is now what 21 behind yeah Don Shula
so
I don't know if you could say you know
travel and then you go for a guy in New
England going to Nantucket I mean that's
not that's a 45-minute ferry ride he's
not going to Nepal
foreign
like I I travel a lot really where do
you go uh 45 minute ferry ride I go to
Nantucket we're going to Braintree yeah
I'm going to Fall River man oh you
better pack for a while you're gonna be
gone uh Tom great to talk to you all
right happy holidays thank you Tom
that's uh Tom Curran the Patriots
Insider NBC Sports Boston made it seem
like you know he's Magellan going around
the globe
Amerigo Vespucci or whatever his name is